with the filming in the prison you're
not alone doing this you have a camera
person with you yes and a sound person
and my co-producer and someone asking
the questions in Hindi so there were a
team of year I think four of us in the
room with him and of course there was a
prison guard present throughout and you
know they've been some ridiculous
accusations that i gave the rapist a
script to read to learn 16 hours i
interviewed mukesh singh really 16 hours
over three days and you know all of
these smear campaigns this desperate
hysterical pathetic attempt of some
sectors of the community in india to not
look in the mirror you know they'll do
anything right well I know you said to
that you thought that it would only be
the rapists or men that were of a
certain educational group that would
have this feeling but you see from the
film that one man says that many of the
members of parliament have unconvicted
rapes and that they've never really been
challenged and it takes so long to see
the process through so this mindset yeah
that says that men and boys are king
they are the desired gender they have
the entitlement and the power and girls
and women are subordinate they are
destined to be domestic slaves to be
married off they don't need an education
and their unwelcome the mother of Jyothi
and they are so enlightened her parents
you know and the mother tells us at one
point that when she had this little girl
she gave out sweets because she was so
happy and the the people who came you
know the friends and family who came to
the the hospital presumably to
saw her given out sweet said you're
celebrating is if you had a boy why are
you giving up sweets I mean literally
that is what they do they don't
celebrate the birth of a girl so if you
grow up as a boy as a man witnessing
this what in God's name do we expect
them to go on to do and express in in
actions when they have this this
attitude bred into them their program
they're hardwired to know that a girl is
of lesser or no value to them and why
are we surprised that they then go and
commit these atrocious and hate-filled
and heinous acts we may as well give
them a rapists manual of for their 11th
birthday
you